[Music]
very excited you have made this film
almost single-handedly it's there
there are many others involved but i did
do a lot of things on it and and uh
terrific being so well received so
congratulations to you and thank you for
i know you're busy right now but you you
know we've known each other a while you
flew out here i did i hope that was an
enjoyable experience i flew well i i
flew out um i'm actually doing kind of a
whirlwind amount i last week in new york
city when our film opened i did 35 q a's
right and then in the weekend in three
days right and uh and then i'm doing uh
six more here in los angeles this
weekend and i'm here on the show i i
actually when i was flying here i got up
so early that i i just uh i was ravenous
when i got to the airport and i just
bought every piece of food they had like
i was just like apples and sandwiches i
don't know what's gonna happen up there
just in case you don't know what they're
serving when they're serving it i've
done that and so i got on the plane i
was eating a chicken salad sandwich and
uh and the flight attendant comes over
and he goes uh excuse me sir um are
there
nuts in that sandwich and and i knew
that there were walnuts in the bread of
the sandwich and i knew that this was
going to go badly so i just kept eating
as
i responded i was like ah i think there
might be
walnuts in the bread you know and
he goes because the woman two seats down
from you she has a nut allergy and so
she could go into shock because of the
nuts and i was like well i won't feed
them to her you know
i won't rub them on her body you know
and uh
and he goes he goes no no it's a it's a
serious allergy where she'll have a
reaction if there are nuts in the air
really
yes i didn't know that i was like if
there are nuts in the air
she should not leave her house
like what that is insane she should
learn how to drive a car yeah so that
way she can she can keep the area uh in
control and so i looked over at the
women and i'm so hungry and i'm halfway
through the sandwich and so i'm intent
on finishing the sandwich and i said um
are you are you serious i go are you
you'll go into reaction there's not in
the air i'm still eating the sandwich
does this happen i didn't think you
would switch to a harmonica
[Applause]
it's the
old chicken sandwich salad sandwich did
he uh
that springsteen used to do quite a bit
in the early 80s the old i love that
tune
and uh i go are you you have reactions
there's nuts in the air and she goes
yeah i'm you know and and i said to the
guy i go is there anywhere where i can
finish this sandwich and i swear to god
he goes you can eat it in the bathroom
really and not the airport bathroom the
airplane bathroom and i swear to god i
said okay and
and i walk back you did that i ate it in
the bathroom i
i didn't know what else to do and not
eat the sandwich is what else you know
it's like he was throwing himself on a
grenade for that woman yeah he had to
get rid of it somehow yeah it was it was
i i was past my point and so i'm eating
the sandwich in the airplane bathroom
and there's all kinds of chemical smells
coming at me and mayonnaise smells hey
no yeah but i had a revelation at that
moment that i
i think i have a fecal airspace allergy
it's not
snow but no really it's a serious thing
it's not just if i eat feces
[Applause]
that was just the right amount of time